Und was gewinnst du dann für Informationen daraus?
Ich finde, das kommt doch mal drauf an, nach was man sucht. Also wenn ich jetzt, was weiß ich, mich informieren will, was das heute passiert, dann guck ich Nachrichten. Und wenn ich aber jetzt zum Beispiel wissen will, was jetzt bei den Themen passiert ist, die sind die letzten drei Wochen so in dieser, quasi so schwer. Also sei es jetzt Iran oder ist es diese Zensursula-Debatte, dann ist Twitter, finde ich, das bessere Medium. Also oder der Einstieg besser.
Wie nimmst du die Iransache wahr?
Das kann ich schwer einschätzen. Also ich bin da nicht so beteiligt. Also ich kann ja zu nichts sagen. Ich weiß nicht, was da wirklich wahr ist. Was nicht. Also ich finde das großartig, dass das da funktioniert und nochmal zurückgeht. Vorhin hat man wohl gesagt, dass der Twitter-Dienst extra seine Wartungsmaschine verschoben hat. Da hatte ich letzte Woche einen Podcast gehört, der H2 der Tag.
Übrigens sehr zu empfehlen.
Ja, da meinten sie, dass das sogar das Gerücht gibt, dass das aufgrund vom amerikanischen Außenministerium angestoßen wurde, dass die das doch bitte verschieben würden wollen.
Ja, das ist bestätigt.
Also das war jetzt nicht der Präsident, der da angerufen hat. Das kam irgendwie aus dem White House irgendwo. Da haben sie halt gesagt, das müsst ihr jetzt nicht unbedingt machen, während da gerade die Demos laufen, sondern macht das mal so, dass das eben jetzt nachts in Iran ist.
Wofür dann die Amerikaner ein bisschen Maintenance-Zeit hinnehmen mussten?
Genau, aber da hat sich dann auch wirklich so recht keiner beschwert drüber.
Aber hier über diese Iran-Geschichte im Speziellen, das hast du ja auch schon ganz richtig erkannt, dass man da auch nicht so richtig sagen kann, was jetzt war oder was falsch ist. Aber was mich da auch sehr fasziniert hat, ist einfach die Fülle der Information und dass es eben auch von allen Seiten kommt. Also es war ja am Anfang sehr aus einer Richtung, sozusagen von den Demonstranten. Und dann kam es halt immer mehr so Tweets dazwischen, so jetzt twittert die Regierung mit und jetzt glaubt man nicht allen, die da was twittern, sondern nur denen, die schon länger twittern und nicht die gestern ersten Account gemacht haben.
Was vielleicht auch bei Iran-Elektrischen, im Gegensatz zu den Zenzursula jetzt als Hashtag, das Problem ist, da wird man echt überfrachtet. Also da twittert ja, sag ich mal, die ganze Welt und bei Zenzursula ist es, ich sag jetzt mal, nur Deutschland.
Ja und das wird halt aber auch alles getwittert, das ganze Spektrum der Information. Also die einen, die posten halt ein Video von einem, der jemandem den Kopf schießt, in Anführungsstrichen, ja und die anderen posten halt Propaganda von wegen, das ist jetzt hier alles gar nicht wahr und Photoshoppen halt irgendwelche Demofotos und laden die hoch. Und man kann halt sich eigentlich auch gar nicht so richtig ein Bild machen, aber es ist trotzdem für mich zumindest sehr faszinierend zu sehen, einfach dieses Spektrum an Information, was da kontinuierlich durch den Kleinen scrollt und man einfach alles kriegt und nicht eben nur das, was CNN jetzt in fünf Minuten Beitrag mal zusammengeschnippelt hat.
Und es lässt dich mit jedem Tweet, den du liest, immer wieder realisieren, dass du nichts glaubst, so wie es auf deinem Bildschirm oder wo auch immer steht, sondern dass du bitte alles hinterfragst.
Genau.
Und immer skeptisch bist über Infos, die dir irgendjemand als gesetzt gibt.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall auch sehr lehrreich, so was zu beobachten, so diesen Informationskrieg live und in Farbe sozusagen.
Ja, ich finde bei Twitter, da kann man auch sehen, wer jetzt eigentlich die Telekommunikation verstanden hat und wer nicht. Ihr hattet das Beispiel mit der SPD, die hat es einfach. Oder die großen Parteien jetzt, ich möchte die SPD da jetzt nicht. Große Vorhaben, die haben es einfach irgendwie verkackt. Ich fand da letzte Woche, das ist auch so ein Punkt, was ich bei Twitter faszinierend finde, da war ja letzte Woche die Diskussion vor der Abstimmung mit dieser Censursular Debatte da, wo die Werte vorher nicht mal anwesend war. Was ich super finde, ist, wenn man auf Fernsehen schaut, solche Debatten und dabei Twitter verfolgt. Also das ist super mitzulesen. Der Taus hat ja glaube ich direkt getwittert von dort. Dann der Max, der auch von schon zitiert wurde. Ich finde das ist super.
Ja, Max saß im Publikum.
Ich finde das super, wenn ich abends vom Fernseher sitze oder abends nach Hause komme, mache den Fernseher an und kann den. Also früher, ich gucke Fernsehen, sehe solche Debatte und denke mir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Und jetzt kann ich direkt bei Twitter mich austauschen und sehe, Gott sei Dank bist du nicht allein.
Genau, das hatten wir vorhin auch schon mal das Gefühl, dass du da nicht alleine bist mit einer Meinung.
Ein kollektives Pfeifen im Wald. Womit man nicht hoffen kann, eine scherzhafte, kollektives Zwitschern im Wald.
Es ist ja auch noch ein ganz interessantes Feature, ich weiß nicht, das hatten wir noch nicht erwähnt, dass man ja die Tweets auch geokodieren kann. Also wenn man zum Beispiel mit dem Mobiltelefon unterwegs ist, dass dann auch deine Koordinaten, wo du gerade bist, mitgeteetet werden können, nicht müssen. So dass zum einen in dem viel zitierten Iran-Beispiel halt die Leute gesagt haben, folgt man wirklich nur den Leuten, die halt auch wirklich in Teheran sind, von den Koordinaten her. Aber ich zum Beispiel hatte auch letztens hier als Tempelhofbesetzung war. Ich wohne da in der Nähe, habe ich dann einfach auch in meinem iPhone mal geklickt. Irgendwie gib mir mal alle Tweets jetzt hier aus 5 km Umgebung und hab dann halt auch dieses Foto von diesem Zivilpolizisten, der da die Knarre zieht, das scrollte da als erstes bei mir im Twitter durch. Weil es einfach in der Nähe war. Und das ist halt eben auch dieses Bahnhofsfeature, was wir vorhin schon hatten.
Der Zug fährt nicht los und keiner sagt dir warum, Twitter sagt es dir dann.
Genau, also das ist halt auch ein echt nettes Feature mit diesen Geokoordinaten.
Lässt sich eigentlich, du hattest gerade erwähnt mit folgt nur den Leuten, die wirklich eine Geoposition im Iran oder Afghanistan oder so, die das da haben, lässt sich das irgendwie manipulieren? Weil die Diskussion ist ja immer wieder da, dass Leute sagen, das kann gar nicht stimmen und ich glaub denen das nicht. Könntest du jetzt von hier aus im Fritz-Studio mit Kraft deines technischen Know-Hows deine Koordinaten so verändern, dass ich glauben würde, du sitzt in Bayern?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall alles andere als unmöglich, ja. Also der Otto-Normalt-Vitera, der wird jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht irgendwie so in sich mal schnell einen Skript hacken, was halt die Geokoordinaten da forcht, also falsche Koordinaten.
Du kannst da eintragen, was du willst, das ist kein sicherer Kenntnis und gerade jetzt im Fall Teheran ist das natürlich jetzt auch gerade ein echtes Problem. Es ging ja wie eine Welle auch wieder durch Twitter, dass man doch bitte als Ort selbst jeder Teheran einstellen soll, damit einfach die Leute, die jetzt wirklich da sind oder sich vorher als dort verortet haben, dem Staat, also den Behörden, die sozusagen gerade auf der Spur sind, nicht auffallen. Ja, wir sind alle Iraner, also das ist das alles sozusagen so eine Nebelwolke.
Und das vor allen Dingen alles innerhalb von weniger als 24 Stunden. Also erst die Entwicklung, jetzt folgt man hier allen aus Teheran und dann oh Moment, keine gute Idee.
Viele sagen auch, wenn ihr irgendwas retweetet, wo ihr wisst, das kommt aus dem Iran, lasst den Namen weg, auch wenn das normalerweise dabei ist, um nicht sozusagen die Quelle zu erschlagen. Und sie kriegen auch aktive Hilfe, auch über Twitter, in dem halt Proxys zugespielt werden, das wird mittlerweile auch nicht mehr öffentlich gemacht, sondern es geht über verschlungene Pfaden. Es gibt halt bestimmte Twitterer, denen man sozusagen vertraut, wo man auch weiß, dass da der Account nicht gehackt wurde, denen werden dann halt Sachen gesteckt und die finden dann natürlich untereinander auch noch andere Wege. Das ist wirklich unglaublich spannend. Wir wissen alle nicht, wie es ausgeht. Wir wissen natürlich auch nicht, welche Dimension es wirklich hat. Aber es ist ganz unzweifelhaft so, dass da jetzt einfach gerade was abgeht, was man so noch nie erlebt hat.
Und das Gefühl, was wir alle haben, wir wissen zu wenig. Du kriegst nicht das mit, weil du willst immer mehr wissen. Es passiert immer wieder, dass dieselbe Meldung nochmal und nochmal und nochmal durchgekaut wird mit dem Experten, der um vier Ecken sitzt, dann nochmal von der anderen Seite beleuchtet wird. Aber sie reden immer noch über das selbe. Du hast das Gefühl, erzähl mir bitte irgendwas Neues. Zum Thema Twitter und Iran haben wir noch Jan am Telefon. Hallo Jan, grüß dich, guten Abend. Hallo.
Ja, ich nutze Twitter eigentlich auch erst seit Kurzem, weil ich immer dachte, um das gescheit machen zu können, da das in Deutschland ja mit SMS nicht geht, braucht man ein Smartphone. Das hatte ich lange Zeit nicht, nun habe ich eins. Und ich bin eigentlich relativ begeistert. Zum einen ist es halt sehr praktisch hier für lokale Aktivitäten und zum anderen eben halt das Thema Iran. Da ist natürlich das eine, man weiß halt nicht genau, ist das jetzt eine authentische Information eben genau dadurch, dass man denjenigen, die man folgt, nicht persönlich kennt und das überhaupt nicht einordnen kann, wenn das genau ist.
Wie nimmst du jetzt sozusagen Teil an Twitter? Liest du vor allem? Schreibst du was?
Beides. Überwiegend lesen momentan. Kommt halt dadurch, dass ich noch relativ neu bin und jetzt auch noch nicht irgendwie...
Das ist immer sehr ratsam, wenn man sich einem neuen Medium nähert, erst mal zu lesen, bevor man schreibt.
Ich soll mal so wie Holgi lachen.
Und wie findest du, also über welche Leute bist du eingestiegen? Wie hast du sozusagen deinen Anfang gemacht? Wem folgst du und woher bekommst du diese Information, wem du folgen könntest?
Ja, das wurde ja immer mehr Thema. Und dann hatte ich halt auch ein Smartphone jetzt. Und dann habe ich das einfach mal angefangen. Und einstieg dann über eine Mailing-Liste, erst mal so in meinem persönlichen Umfeld, was mich so interessiert, da erst mal gefragt, hallo wer twittert und das und das und da könnt ihr folgen und meldet euch mal.
Also über deine Freunde, sozusagen.
Genau.
Und nutzt ihr das dann auch innerhalb eures Freundeskreises so für private Aktivitäten? Party, Verabredungen?
Noch relativ eingeschränkt. Ich denke mal, das hängt einfach damit zusammen, dass noch nicht jeder so ein Smartphone hat. Weil ich glaube in Deutschland, um es vernünftig nutzen zu können, braucht es einfach ein Smartphone. Gerade auch wenn man irgendwelchen Links oder so, dann tut es eine SMS oder so ja doch nicht, wobei das ja in Deutschland auch wieder nicht geht. Also ohne Smartphone, glaube ich, verliert das sehr viel an Wert.
Na gut, aber man kann es ja auch an seinem Rechner machen.
Ja, sicherlich. Aber dann hat man halt diesen Aktualitätsbonus nicht. Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie abends oder so am Rechner sitzt, dann gibt es ja doch bessere Möglichkeiten als 140 Zeichen, obwohl sich auch damit schon sehr viel sagen lässt.
Wobei ja es auch ganz viele Leute gibt, die tatsächlich so einen Bürojob am Computer haben und den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen.
Da muss ich sagen, bei uns auf der Arbeit habe ich zum Beispiel ein Proxy, die sperren doch tatsächlich Twitter. Da bin ich ja schockiert.
Aber du kannst auch Twitter auch über HTTPS benutzen, das werden sie bestimmt nicht durch ihren Proxy kriegen. Und da man HTTPS schon ab und zu mal braucht, ist das meistens kein Problem. Nur mal so als Tipp. Interessanter Punkt, was diese Unsperrbarkeit jetzt im Iran von Twitter betrifft. Man könnte ja sagen, wieso machen die nicht einfach Twitter zu? Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie es da aussieht. Ich denke mir, das Twitter-Portal als solches dürfte da definitiv nicht zu erreichen sein. Aber es gibt ja viele andere Wege. Das wurde ja vorhin auch schon angesprochen. Diese API, diese Programmschnittstellen. Das heißt, man hat ein Programm auf seinem eigenen Rechner laufen und das redet halt mit dem Twitter. Und da gibt es eben viele Wege, die da hinfügen. Und andere Webseiten können mir auch einen Zugang zu Twitter bieten, indem sie mir halt ein Webinterface bieten und ich twittere dort und die schmeißen das hinten rein. Und das ist halt der Grund, warum Twitter da auch derzeit so nicht zu stoppen ist.
Gesetzt den Fall, jetzt das Szenario gesponnen, sollten sie Twitter abschalten oder irgendwie sperren, wird natürlich die twitternde Gemeinde, wird sich das ganz schnell rumsprechen und der Link zur Abhilfe ist innerhalb von Sekunden bei dir.
Jaja, trotzdem. Ich meine, man darf sich jetzt auch nicht der Illusion hingeben, dass man überall drumherum kommt. Diese Zensur, diese Internetzensur im Iran, ist da auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Das ist ja auch von Deutschland gelieferte Technik.
Teilweise Siemens, Nokia, Konglomerat, den Firmen haben jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau im Kopf.
Wo hast du denn diese Information her? Aus dem Internet etwa?
Hast du auf Twitter gelesen, ne?
Das ist ja nicht per se eine schlechte Informationsquelle, im Gegenteil.
Okay, aber feil an der Halbwissen.
Ja, wie auch immer. Es ist vollkommen klar. Ja, also ich meine, dass es diese Sperrtechniken gibt und dass die in Deutschland genauso wie in den USA und überall hergestellt werden, das ist ja auch kein Geheimnis. Also diese Technologie ist verfügbar und sie wird halt auch immer wieder so mit diesem Argument Kinderschutz natürlich auch gerne verkauft, was ja auch jetzt gerade diese Maßnahme hier mit diesem KIPO-Gesetz so per viele macht. Weil man damit halt immer alles verkaufen kann und immer glaubt, keiner würde sich wehren. Und es wehrt sich auf einmal das Netz trotzdem und alle sind überrascht. Wie, was, ihr wollt das diskutieren? Sowas wird doch nicht diskutiert. Doch, wir diskutieren das jetzt. Und zwar in aller Öffentlichkeit und mit einer Bandbreite. Dieser schöne Tweet, der vorhin schon genannt wurde, den Max mal gebracht hat. Ihr werdet euch noch wünschen, wir werden Politik verdrossen.
Zu dem Thema Twitter gibt ein neues Level in Sachen Demokratie. Holen wir uns nochmal Sandra ins Boot. Jan und René, euch beide schicke ich jetzt in die Nacht. Tschüss, danke für den Anruf. Ihr seid übrigens im Chaosradio auf Fritz03317097110 und die nächste haben Telefone Sandra. Guten Abend Sandra. Zum Thema Twitter und Demokratie. Holen wir dich mit ins Boot. Was möchtest du sagen?
Genau, da ist mir letztens ein Tweet aufgefallen von jemandem, der gesagt hat, Twitter ist eine Blase.
Eine Blase?
Eine Blase. Wir sind ja alle in dem Twitter drin und merken das alles und bekommen die ganzen Tweets mit. Aber ganz, ganz viele Leute außerhalb des Internets oder sagen wir mal Leute, die nur eine Stunde am Tag im Internet sind, die bekommen überhaupt nicht mit, was da alles passiert. Und die spricht man dann oft in Sosula an oder auf Iran-Election oder sowas und dann sagen die, ja, keine Ahnung, was ist da passiert? Oder sagen halt, ja, das hab ich auch gelesen in der Zeitung. Aber ich hab das Gefühl, das ist nur in Twitter so richtig gehypt und ansonsten bekommen die Leute das kaum mit, halt nur noch über Medien.
Aber wir beobachten ja auch, dass Twitter jetzt in zunehmendem Maße auch für die normalen Medien die Quelle wird. Da gab es diese schöne Tagesschau, da mit dem Iran, wo sie meinten so, ja, man kann das ja immer alles nicht überprüfen. Es ist auch so lustig, wie sie immer darauf hinweisen, ja, das sind ja alles so Quellen, da weiß man ja nicht, ob es stimmt. Als ob das jetzt beim normalen Fernsehen jemals anders gewesen wäre. Wer glaubt, was im Fernsehen gebracht wird, dem gehört auch mal der Kopf gewaschen. Das ist einfach eine genauso unzuverlässige Quelle. Und dieses ganze Gewusel, man muss ja das alles zweimal lesen. Das kann ich jedem nur raten, wenn man auch die traditionellen Medien konsumiert. Auch Chaosradio. Und das wird natürlich jetzt sehr deutlich. Ich finde es sehr gut, dass sich jetzt herumgesprochen hat, dass man vielleicht auch mal seine Quellen selber checken sollte. Und Hirn einschalten ist generell immer zu empfehlen. Schön fand ich dann auch diesen Spruch in der Tagesschau, als sie dann diese Videos zeigen, da sie ja selber nichts in der Hand hatten. Alle ihre Journalisten wurden dann des Landes verwiesen oder durften nicht mehr den Raum verlassen. Dann so, ja, wir zeigen jetzt Videos, die es bisher so nur im Internet zu sehen gab. Da müssen wir gleich lachen, so, ha ha, nur im Internet, ihr seid ja lustig, ist klar. Das zeigt natürlich auch deutlich, wie diese Wahrnehmung ist. Aber ich denke, das ändert sich jetzt. Denkst du das nicht auch?
Unterschiedlich, also es sind vor allen Dingen halt die höheren Schichten, die gewilderten Leute, die halt das Internet richtig nutzen, vielleicht richtig, die das Internet überhaupt nutzen. Und alle anderen, die vielleicht in der Schule mal ins Internet können, die sind dann irgendwie ausgeschlossen. Die dann halt zu StudiVZ gehen oder zu Facebook, oder was weiß ich nicht alles.
Wir holen an der Stelle mal die Generation StudiVZ Facebook mit ins Boot. Wir haben Alexander am Telefon, der ist 18. Und der will was sagen zu der twitternden und der nicht twitternden Bevölkerung. Hallo Alexander. Grüß dich. Das was Samra gerade sagt, würdest du da mitgehen? Dass Twitter eine Blase ist? Dass Twitter eine Blase ist und dass die, die drin sind, das alles super finden und die, die draußen sind, kriegen es nicht mit?
Also ich bin jetzt seit über ein Jahr dabei bei Twitter und ganz am Anfang sowieso. Also ganz kleine Blase. Aber mittlerweile merkt man es auch schon, dass auch immer mehr in den Zeitungen, zum Beispiel bei Die Welt und so, kommt es jetzt immer mehr, dass zum Beispiel Tweet des Tages und sowas gibt es jetzt da auch schon. Und meine Mutter kommt auch rein und sagt, ja, hallo, heute in Twitter, da war irgendwie ein Virus oder so. Und dann sag ich, hä? Und man merkt halt, es kommt immer mehr in die, in die normale Gesellschaft halt auch mit rein. Aber es ist in gewisser Weise immer noch eine Blase mit ein paar kleinen Löchern.
Ich bekomme übrigens gerade auch ein Tweet, das unter Fashion-Bloggern angeblich auch sehr beliebt ist, um neueste Fashion-Trends zu verfolgen. Also ich sehe das ja auch so, aber prinzipiell ist es auch so, ich meine, die Leute, die halt nur Bildzeitungen lesen wollen, die lesen halt nur Bildzeitungen. Und die Leute, die ein bisschen mehr Interesse haben, die kaufen sich halt mal die Zeit oder noch eine andere Zeitung und lesen halt auch quer. Also das würde ich jetzt gar nicht mal so aufs Medium beschränken, sondern das ist halt einfach ein generelles Interesse. Will ich wirklich wissen, was da ist oder reicht mir, wenn ich jetzt hier auf Seite 1 der Mädel sehe und noch den Wetterbericht habe?
Wie viel deiner Zeit würdest du weggeben, um dich mit so viel Information zu versorgen, dass du dich informiert fühlst? Ich? Nee, aber das ist so die Frage, die da so dahinter steht. Alexander, wie ist das so in deinem Umfeld? Bei deinen Freunden oder bei den Leuten, die aus der Schule sind die auch bei Twitter oder ist das eher so die Studi-VZ-Abteilung?
Leider. Also von meiner Ausbildung hier in der Berufsschule kommen jetzt aus meiner Berufsklasse 1, 2, schön langsam dazu. Also es ist alles sehr fließend. Ich sehe da noch nicht so den Hype in der normalen Bevölkerung, dass das jetzt halt immer mehr kommt. In den USA ist ja anscheinend um einiges mehr als bei uns jetzt hier in Deutschland. Und ich muss auch sagen, viele sagen halt einfach erstmal, hä, was ist denn Twitter oder auch jetzt mit der Zensursala-Diskussion. Die haben das auch gar nicht so mitgekriegt, auch wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so einen Beruf hat wie Fachinformatiker. Wenn ich damit mit Leuten rede über die Zensur-Debatte, ich habe mir den Mund fußlich geredet, wochenlang da jetzt halt hier die Petition und so und die haben halt gesagt, interessiert mich doch nicht und brauche ich mich, hab doch Internet und ich hab doch nichts zu verbergen, immer diese berühmten Kastanen. Und ich bin halt der Meinung, dass man sich halt auch politisch ein bisschen engagieren soll und auch ruhig seine Grundgesetze wahrhaben sollte und zwar das mit der Meinungsfreiheit. Auch wenn es jetzt erstmal so ist, meine Freundin hat neulich mal irgendwie in meinen Blog geschaut und da meinte sie so, hey, was, du bloggst ja hier über Politik und so, ist das dann jetzt nicht schlecht, wenn da mal jemand einstellen möchte. Da steht dann deine politische Aussage drin.
Aber sprichst du mit deiner Freundin im Real Life nicht auch über Politik? Ist dir das komplett neu, dass du das im Netz machst?
Nee, nee, das mach ich schon auch mit ihr. Aber im Netz ist es halt für alle. Das war halt das, was sie eher so abgeschreckt hat, denke ich mal. Und ich bin aber schon der Meinung, dass man halt seine politische Meinung oder die Diskussion über diese Themen auch ruhig öffentlich machen soll und nicht nur halt immer im kleinen Kreis, vielleicht nur Familie oder so, am Abend-Tisch, am Stammtisch irgendwie. Und dann passiert sowieso nichts, weil jeder meint, das ist so und so. Und dann kommt danach nichts dabei raus, weil es war halt bloß eine Gruppe von zehn Leuten oder so. Und so trägt man das halt an die Öffentlichkeit halt auch. Und man sieht es jetzt auch bei Twitter, da hat ja die Petition, die hat ja über Twitter einen Hype bekommen. Das war ja echt ein Wahnsinn. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich fand es auch richtig toll zu sehen, dass man halt, wie Sie schon mehrere gesagt haben, man ist halt nicht alleine mit seiner Meinung. Und das Medium Twitter, das unterstützt einen das sehr, halt auch über sowas zu diskutieren und Meinungen auszutauschen.
Zu diesem Hinweis mit irgendwie ja, die allgemeine Bevölkerung und so. Klar, dass ist natürlich, dass der Großteil der Leute in unserer Gesellschaft nicht bereit ist, in solchen Diskussionen teilzunehmen und schon gar nicht bereit ist, im Internet an solchen Diskussionen teilzunehmen. Das wissen wir alle. Das ist auch etwas, was sich jetzt durch den Generationenwandel auf gewisse Art und Weise von alleine löst. Was ich aber ganz interessant finde ist, dass jetzt eben durch, nicht nur durch Twitter, es ist mir auch alles ein bisschen zu Twitter zentriert. Es gibt natürlich auch noch andere, wir gehen auch nochmal drauf ein. Aber was halt jetzt sozusagen diese neue, noch nähere Vernetzung bewirkt ist, dass eben diese Elite, die sehr wohl bereit ist, sich inhaltlich zu engagieren und zu diskutieren, dass die jetzt auch eine Plattform dafür hat, das zu tun und sie tut es dann eben auch. Und das ist natürlich viel wichtiger, weil letzten Endes wird diese Gesellschaft von Eliten gesteuert und es gibt da halt Eliten, die sind halt einfach daran interessiert, dass der Status quo erhalten bleibt. Und es gibt eben eine neue Elite, die eben damit nicht einverstanden ist. Und da finden ja auch die Auseinandersetzungen tatsächlich statt. Man muss nicht jetzt jeden auf Twitter zerren. Aber wichtig ist, dass man die Multiplikatoren, die Leute, die eine Meinung haben und die auch bereit sind, sie zu diskutieren und zu vertreten, dass man die eben mit in die Diskussionsrunde wirft. Und die Möglichkeit gibt es jetzt in zunehmendem Maße.
Ich würde auch sowieso nicht sagen, dass jetzt halt Twitter für alle Zeiten das Allheilmittel ist. Also sagen wir mal, Twitter wird morgen verkauft und dann ist alles ganz blöd. Dann gibt es halt den nächsten Service. Und der ist dann vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen besser. Und ich sehe da halt einfach generell den Trend, dass den Sieg ist zu des Web, sozusagen das Mitmach-Webs. Dass es einfach immer einfacher wird, sich selbst zu broadcasten und sich mit anderen zu vernetzen. Und Twitter ist halt jetzt einfach gerade das Medium, was am größten ist und am aktivsten. Und das wird sich bestimmt auch nochmal ändern.
Es gab auch Zeiten noch, da haben die Leute gesagt, wozu brauche ich denn auf meinem Mobiltelefon die Möglichkeit, da eine kurze Textnachricht zu verschicken. Ich kann ja auch anrufen, das brauche ich alles auch nicht. Mittlerweile ist das ein normaler Teil unseres Lebens. Und so wird es mit Twitter irgendwann auch sein. Damit sind wir nochmal bei der Blase, wo ihr sagt, wir sind jetzt noch in diesem Luftballon drin. Und der Rest der Welt ist da draußen.
Die Blase wird größer.
Wir können alle nicht in die Zukunft gucken, vielleicht gibt es irgendwann etwas mit Fashionbloggern oder mit Süßigkeiten, ich habe keine Ahnung, mit irgendwas vollkommen Banalem zu tun hat, wo die Welt sagt, super, das kann man mit Twitter machen sofort. Wo mich dann mein Vater anrufen würde und würde sagen, wie geht das wirklich machen?
Genau, das ist doch die richtige Strategie, den Leuten das mitzugeben. Also das, was im Internet diskutiert wird, auf die Straße zu tragen, in die Familie zu tragen, in die Schule, in die Uni zu treiben, wo auch immer hin.
Und das ist ja auch sehr schön, an dieser ganzen Diskursion, gerade bei Zensur, ich hab das jetzt bei vielen hier auch schon zwischen den Zeilen rausgelesen. Und ich hab das auch sehr häufig gehört. Viele nehmen halt über Twitter oder was auch immer an dieser Debatte teil und fühlen sich einmal hochmotiviert zu dieses, wir sind nicht allein, ja, fühlen sich hochmotiviert, das in ihre Familien, ihre Peer-Gruppen, ihren Freundeskreis, ihre Firma, was auch immer reinzutragen. Natürlich mit gemischtem Erfolg, wie das immer so ist, aber der Erfolg ist natürlich definitiv größer, wenn das getan wird, als wenn es komplett unterlassen werden würde. Das hat auch, glaube ich, zu dem Erfolg dieser Online-Petition beigetragen. Und das wird dann auch in zunehmendem Maße dazu beitragen, dass diese Diskussion auch weitergeht. Wird jetzt sehr spannend, zum Beispiel, gerade bei der Zellensurseler Debatte. Man könnte ja sagen, das ist ja jetzt vorbei, das Gesetz ist ja beschlossen. Zwei Tage später geht das weiter mit bundesweiten Demonstrationen. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sich das Ganze noch mal bis zur Bundestagswahl in irgendeiner Form trägt.
Hier wird jetzt, also ich weiß nicht, wollen wir ja noch kurz mal nur, damit was gesagt haben, noch die anderen Dienste mal kurz abhandeln. Also nachgucken könnt ihr dann selber bei Wikipedia, was das macht. Also es gibt halt noch einen großen anderen, der heißt Identica. Und dahinter steht auch ein Open Source System, was ihr euch dann selber auch auf dem Server installieren könnt. Dann gibt es noch Jaiku. Und irgendwas...
Gibt es das noch? Nee, ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr? Schon verkauft?
Was gibt es noch?
Also es guckt einfach, wenn er bei Twitter auf Wikipedia guckt, dann kriegt er auch die alternativen Dienste.
Also Twitter, es gibt ja auch einen technischen Begriff für Twitter. Der wird wenig bemüht. Microblogging. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen das, was Twitter tut. Und es verdichtet sich halt jetzt alles auf Twitter, weil natürlich allein das Microblogging, nur der Dienst als solcher, ist ja erstmal nichts ohne die Leute. Und so wie sich es eben entwickelt hat, dadurch, dass Twitter eben auch die ersten waren, und sie auch genug getan haben, um selbst am Ball der Leute, die es benutzen, dran zu bleiben, ist es einfach jetzt der Ort, wo alle sind. Das kann man gut finden, das kann man schlecht finden, aber es ist einfach ein Fakt. Und das macht eben diesen Kanal so wertvoll.
Und die Vergrößerung des Mediums, oder die Vergrößerung des Kanals, hängt sicherlich auch damit zusammen, wie schnell es möglich ist, Internet überall hin mitzunehmen. Weil klar, kannst du mit dem Smartphone irgendwie dein Internet mitnehmen, jeder hat so ein Ding, es geht nicht überall. Viele müssen an den Rechner, wo das Internet dran ist, um sich dann da damit zu beschäftigen. Das heißt, du kannst nicht einfach mal aus der Straße oder in der Region dich irgendwie da einloggen und gucken, wie es funktioniert. Aber auch das ist eine technische Entwicklung, die vorwärts geht und die hoffentlich in den nächsten Jahren dann...
In Iran lief es ja auch so, dass sie dann einfach Leute lokal angerufen haben, wo sie wussten, die haben jetzt einen Nachbarn mit Internet und haben das dann halt so über drei Ecken weitergetragen.
Aber es ist schön zu sehen, wie einfach der technische Fortschrift an der Stelle auch wieder greift. Was vorhin erwähnt wurde, die Sendung von hr2dertag, die du gelobt hast, ich lobe die auch gleich nochmal, die sind übrigens auch auf Twitter jetzt mit der Tag, derzeit nur Ankündigung, mal gucken, vielleicht kann man mit denen auch bald mal diskutieren. Die haben dann auch nochmal so diesen Rückblick gemacht, wie denn das eigentlich bei der ersten oder bei der letzten Revolution im Iran gelaufen ist, also als Khomeini an die Macht kam. Und das Interessante war, dass die Botschaften, also damals war ja im Prinzip genau die gleiche Situation. Da war halt der Shah, Esar-Esa Pahlavi, der hat halt alles unter Kontrolle gehabt und die Medien und so weiter, mit Ausnahme der Moscheen. Und die Botschaften von Khomeini, seine Reden, wurden mit Magnetbändern, also mit Tapes, ins Land gebracht und dann eben kopiert und eben verteilt. Und das hat eben dazu geführt, dass eben, ja das war sozusagen, also das Twitter der frühen 80er-Jahre war halt das Magnetband, der Kompaktkassette. Und jetzt ist halt das Internet.
Machen wir an der Stelle einen kurzen Punkt. Ich gucke auf die Uhr, wir machen jetzt gleich Nachrichten. Und danach machen wir weiter am Chaosradio. Wir haben ja noch eine Menge Leute. Habt ein bisschen Geduld, fünf Minuten sind wir gleich wieder da. 0331 70 97 1 1 0. Alexander und Sandra, euch einen schönen Abend.
Live und neu und gut. Fritz empfiehlt. Live im LIDO Berlin. Live im Glashaus in der Arena Berlin Treptow. Wann genau und wo genau?
Fritzee.
Genau. La Rue, The Hilltaboods und Klee Zee. Live von Neu und Gut.
Nachricht.
Genau um halb 12 mit Mario Bartsch.
Bei einem Anschlag in der irakischen Hauptstadt Bagdad sind am Abend mindestens 60 Menschen getötet worden. Nach Angaben der Behörden explodierte die Bomber auf einem belebten Markt. Über 150 weitere Menschen wurden verletzt. Erst am Montag waren in Bagdad mehrere Menschen getötet worden, als ein Sprengsatz neben einem Bus mit Oberschülern explodierte. Das Überleben des insolventen Versandhauses Quelle ist vorerst gesichert. Der Bürgschaftsausschuss von Bund und Ländern einigte sich darauf, Quelle einen Kredit zur Verfügung zu stellen. Der Bund und die Länder Bayern und Sachsen teilen sich das Darlehen von 50 Millionen Euro. Zuvor hatte es der Bund abgelehnt, Quelle eine Bürgschaft zu geben, da das Ausfallrisiko zu groß sei. Die schwedische Internettauschbörse Pirate Bay kommt wieder vor Gericht. Sie wurde von einer niederländischen Copyright-Organisation verklagt. Die drei Gründer von Pirate Bay waren im April zu je einem Jahr Haft und fast drei Millionen Euro Schadenersatz verurteilt worden. Sie hatten über die Webseite links für das kostenlose Herunterladen von Musik, Filmen und Software veröffentlicht. Die deutschen Handballer haben bei der EM 2010 in Österreich eine schwere Vorrundengruppe erwischt. Sie müssen gegen Vize-Weltmeister Polen, gegen Schweden und Slowenien antreten. Da gab es heute die Auslosung in Wien. Die EM findet im Januar statt. Die Fußball-Nationalmannschaft der USA steht überraschend im Finale das Confederation Cup in Südafrika. Der Außenseiter hat das Halbfinale gegen Europameister Spanien mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen. Der Finalgegner wird morgen zwischen Brasilien und Gastgeber Südafrika ermittelt. Das Endspiel findet dann am Sonntag statt.
Wetter.
Heute Nacht im Süden noch einzelne Schauer und Gewitter, später wechselnd bewölkt und zunächst kaum Regen. Die Tiefstwerte liegen bei 12 Grad. Der Tag beginnt dann mit Schauern und Gewittern, die von Hoda und Neise herankommen. Es gibt viele Wolken und immer wieder Regen bei maximal 22 Grad. A10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck Werder, zwischen Rangsdorf und Genshagen gibt es Fahrbahn-Erneuerungen, deswegen sind dort zwei Spuren gesperrt. A12, Berlin, Richtung Frankfurt-Oder, zwischen Friedersdorf und Storkow liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Besonders vorsichtig dort ist ganz auf der linken Spur. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin, A113, der Zubringer Schönfeld, Stadt Einwärts. Zwischen Adlershof und Spätstraße ist die Autobahn wegen Instandhaltungsarbeiten gesperrt. Sonst überall eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, Mittwochabend. Huckel ist hier, Tim ist hier, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Twitter und die Twitter Demokratie ist heute unser Thema. Kabel Granz kurz während der Nachrichten gerade in die Tweets gegucken, da ist einer drin, da steht, ich werde irgendwie das Gefühl nicht los, dass sich ein Haufen Leute jetzt nur wegen Chaosradio angemeldet haben. Ob das positiv oder negativ zu werten ist, sei mal dahingestellt. Wenn es aber so ist, dass ihr euch deswegen angemeldet habt, herzlichen Glückwunsch, herzlich willkommen.
Ja, da muss man sich auch nicht so viel Gedanken drum machen.
Ja, aber es ist so, du hast ja immer was.
Ich könnte mir schlechtere Gründe vorstellen, warum man sich bei Twitter anwendet.
Aber es gibt auch was Neues und die Leute, die es schon haben, sind natürlich total dabei, finde ich super. Und je mehr Leute dazu kommen, desto...
Ein bisschen leiser nur mein Kopf hörst.
Also ich finde Twitter skaliert da ganz gut. Da wo das Kabel aus dem Tisch kommt, da ist ein Lautstärkeknopf. Hallo Huckel. Wunderbar geht. Es ist doch eigentlich dann egal, das ist doch so langweilig.
Es gibt auch echt viele Leute, die sich dann anmelden, weil sie halt auch diesen sozialen Zwang spüren und dann aber auch irgendwie gar nichts damit anzufangen, bis man den Account wieder verstauben lassen. Also es ist...
Na so ist das halt.
So ist das halt, genau.
Wir wollten nochmal auf die Follower eingehen und ich hoffe, Christoph ist noch am Telefon, der wartet schon seit fast einer guten Stunde. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend, hier ist Jakob.
So, ich bin dran. Hallo, es piept etwas, hoffe ich nicht.
Nee, aber wir können dich wunderbar hören.
Okay, mein Telefon geht nämlich langsam im Geist auf. Ja, ich bin, ich hab mal vorhin nachgeschaut, tatsächlich schon seit Oktober 07, war dabei, aber ich hab irgendwie die ersten anderthalb Jahre so gut wie nix gemacht, weil ich auch das Gefühl hatte, da tauscht man sich aus, wann man Kaffee trinkt und wann man vorm Rechner sitzt. Aber dann irgendwie kam es, ich glaub auch über Tim, dass es interessant wurde. Und ich hab relativ schnell, weil ich zu Anfang relativ persönliche Sachen mit ein paar Freunden aufgetauscht hab, meinen Account geschlossen gelassen. Also sprich, ich muss bestätigen, wenn mir jemand folgt oder nicht folgt. Und das fand ich auch, hab ich immer noch. Das schränkt mich zwar ein, weil ich wieder gefunden werde durch eine Suche, aber ich hab irgendwie das Gefühl, ich will nicht mit jedem reden. Also ich will auch nicht jedem irgendwie meinen Mist zumuten, in Anführungsstrichen. Und wenn, finde ich es eigentlich sehr nett, wenn ich die Leute irgendwo zumindest durch den Chat oder sonst wie persönlich kenne, da wo, wenn ich den folge, ich glaub auch, dass es irgendwann, ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie man es schafft, mehr als 1000 Leute zu folgen, die einigermaßen aktiv sind. Das rattert dann wahrscheinlich nur so durch. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie glaube ich 40 Leute drauf, die ich kenne, die ich meistens auch persönlich richtig kenne. Das ist schon reichlich, also wenn ich mich abends an den Rechner setze und ich will den Tag über nachgucken, was da getweetet worden sind, oder sind 200 Stück, dann ist das schon eine Menge.
Ja, das ist natürlich so eine Unsitte. Es gibt so Leute, die folgen anderen Leuten und lesen das gar nicht. Das kann man meiner Meinung nach allein schon daran festmachen. Also wenn es eine vierstellige Zahl ist, dann ist das einfach schon mal bekloppt. Und der einzige Grund ist halt der, dass sie einem folgen mit dem Wunsch, selber zurückgefolgt zu werden, um dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, sich toller zu fühlen.
Es gibt auch ganz viele Bots natürlich, die so aggregieren und irgendwie auf jedes Keyword anspringen. Und dann irgendwie, sobald du irgendwas über Apple twitters, hast du dann 23 Apple-Aggregatoren-Bots an der Backe.
Also ich mach das immer so. Also wenn das so offensichtlich Leute sind, die zehnmal so viele Leute folgen wie ihnen folgen, dann block ich die meistens. Es sei denn, es gibt da irgendwie einen besonders guten Grund, aber mir fallen da nicht viele gute Gründe ein, die man haben könnte. Ansonsten eine Alternative zu diesem Problem mit, ich bin oft mal so richtig geschlossen ist man ja auch nicht, wenn man seine Tweets sperrt. Klar, man kommt über das normale Interface nicht rein, aber was ist, wenn du was Cooles sagst und jemand retweetet das? Ja, dann ist es irgendwie genauso offen. Man kann es natürlich auch andersrum machen. Man ist einfach offen, man ist auch suchbar und findbar. Aber wenn man jetzt irgendwie partout irgendjemand nicht permanent immer das Neueste vor die Nase schmeißt, dann blockt man ihn einfach. Kann er zwar theoretisch dann auch noch irgendwie nachschlagen, aber man ist dann schon mal sozusagen, ja, muss man, das ist halt mal wieder, da braucht man so die private Medienkompetenz, da muss man eben selber sehen, wie man damit umgeht. Ist alles in Ordnung.
Also ich fand es ganz interessant, als es für mich interessant wurde, als ich wirklich so Politiker leute, ich meine, ich kenne jetzt lustigerweise auch noch persönlich, ich kann da Volker Beck namentlich nennen, der relativ früh ziemlich aktiv war, der sogar auch für, ich glaube, für von der Rheinischen Post jemand hatte, der mit jemand tatsächlich sonntags irgendwie eine Interview geführt hat über Twitter, das dann in der Zeitung abgedruckt wurde, war so eine ganz lustige Idee. Mit Bütikova fand ich, der hat das auch dazugelernt, der hat am Anfang versucht, wirklich seine Interviews über Twitter zu publizieren, also dass da wirklich so 20 Tweets hintereinander kam, fand ich sehr unangenehm. Mit der Zeit ist er besser geworden, das sind so Sachen, die muss man lernen. Und darüber fand ich eine ganz lustige Sache, dass man so als gewisse, ich hab das zuerst mit Zensula gesehen, dass man sich reingeschrieben hat, irgendwie überschrieben hat, dass man eine gewisse Sympathie zu pflegt oder dagegen diese für die Petition oder jetzt halt mit dem Errat, dass es so ein Tool im Prinzip gab, was das eigene Icon grün gefärbt hat. Fand ich irgendwie eine ganz nette Idee.
Als farblichen Hinweis.
Genau, wenn man auf die Follower geguckt hat von jemanden, so finde ich auch am interessantesten, dass man selber Leute findet, die interessant sind. Wenn man Leute hat, die man selber kennt, dass man guckt, wem folgen die denn? Und dann eben sieht man ganz schnell, dass da irgendwie 20 auf einmal grün gefärbt sind. Und das fand ich irgendwie wirklich eine ganz nette Idee. Ein Aspekt, der mir noch einfällt, was noch überhaupt nicht gedacht wird, das wird ja alles irgendwie gespeichert. Und wie lange wird das aufgehoben, was wir jetzt alle twittern? Weil ich kann nachgucken. Meinen ersten Tweet hab ich nachgeguckt, der tatsächlich irgendwie von Oktober 07 war. Gucke gerade Fernsehen. Das wird mir gelöscht. Ich mein, selbst Google sagt irgendwie, die löschen nach acht Monaten oder neun Monaten. Twitter löscht, vergisst scheinbar gar nichts.
Nö, ist ja bloggen. Aber du kannst es ja selber löschen.
Und dann steht es immer noch im Webarchive.
Ja, und das finde ich halt... Prinzipiell bin ich immer so ein bisschen skeptisch bei diesen Diensten, die nichts kosten. Sodass ich mich irgendwo frage... Ich hab's natürlich irgendwo kapiert. Auch YouTube, ist klar, dass sie irgendwann Geld damit verdienen wollten, tun sie immer noch nicht. Aber so denke ich so ein bisschen, wer weiß, wo das noch alles ausgewertet wird. Also ich will ja nicht die großen Verschwörungstheorien machen, aber irgendwo finde ich es zum Teil schon so ein bisschen fragwürdig, dass das ewig aufgehoben wird.
Ja gut, da kann man ja nur zu sagen, also so ist das, ja. Also wir leben jetzt in der digitalen Welt, da wird kopiert und gespeichert und das Netz vergisst wenig.
Aber Christoph hat schon recht an dem Punkt. Also auch CCC und auch Chaosradio und Chaosradio Express und alle, was immer eine Adresse ist, die sich für Datenschutz ausspricht, für eine vorsichtige Preisgabe von persönlichen Daten. Und dann mit der Huratwitterfahne loszurennen.
Ja gut, aber Datenschutz ist, wie andere mit deinen Daten umgehen. Die Frage ist, wie geht man selber mit seinem eigenen Kommunikationsverhalten um? Ich habe ja genau das gleiche Problem. Ich bin extrem belegbar. Ich denke, man muss da auch einfach dann zu einer gewissen digitalen Aufrichtigkeit übergehen und einfach konsistent sein in dem, wie man ist. Dann ist das auch kein Problem, dass man gespeichert wird.
Aber ist ja irgendwie so ein bisschen die Haltung so, dieses ich hab nichts zu verbergen, also brauche ich nichts zu befürchten, so ein bisschen. Das ist ja eigentlich das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann. Warum hast du Angst, wenn deine Telefongespräche gespeichert werden?
Niemand zwingt dich ja dazu, dass du jetzt irgendwie sensitive Informationen oder private Gespräche über Twitter austrägst. Und wenn du das halt machst, dann kann dir halt auch keiner mehr helfen. Die Medienkompetenz, das muss man schon...
Ja, Telefongespräche ist was Privates. Wenn du öffentlich bloggst, und das ist das, was du tust bei Twitter, auch wenn es Microblogging ist, dann tust du das halt öffentlich. Sich dann darüber zu beschweren, dass die Öffentlichkeit das speichert, das hilft natürlich wenig. Wenn du das nicht willst, dann darfst du das nicht benutzen.
Was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was ganz interessant wäre, wenn es so ein automatisches Übersetzungs-Tour gäbe. Also was mir gerade aufgefallen ist, gerade diese arabischen Tweets, die ich jetzt bekommen hab, die ich dann immer bei Google Übersetzung eingegeben hab, das war zum Teil ziemlich schwierig.
Bestimmt im nächsten Twitter-Client mit eingebaut.
Ja, das wäre vielleicht ganz spannend, dass wir so eine universale Sprache dann...
Ja, Google hat sowas schon. Das haben sie ja vor einem Monat demonstriert, als sie da ihr neues Wave-Produkt gemacht haben. Die ziehen tatsächlich ihren ganzen Webindex jetzt auch dazu heran, Übersetzungen zu machen. Das wird glaube ich nicht mehr so lange dauern, dann wird es noch spannender.
Und dann wollte ich noch einen Gruß in Chat loswerden, da ist sehr sehr aktiv, hab ich das Gefühl.
Ja, es rauscht durch.
Danke Christoph. Lade deinen Akku, tschüss.
Ja, der Chat, der rauscht hier.
Ein etabliertes Medium auch, das Irr ist auch nicht totzukriegen.
Da kommt jetzt ein anderer Christoph ans Telefon, der auch eine kritische Stimme zu Twitter hat. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend. Hallo grüß dich. Du sagst, Blogs sind viel schöner, und Twitter ist überbewertet. Warum denn?
Also das Ganze ist jetzt momentan halt ein Hype, weil sehr viele Leute drum twittern. Aber die meisten Tweets, die ich lese, sind eigentlich wirklich nur irgendwelche Links auf, vielleicht lese ich auch die Frage, irgendwelche Links auf irgendwelche Blogs oder irgendwelche News Seiten oder sowas. Und ich weiß nicht, also ich finde, das haben Blogs schon vorher gemacht und auf andere Seiten verlinkt. Und es ist halt mehr so eine Linksammlung, aber da gibt es ja auch, also ich meine, dafür ist es ja nicht gedacht worden.
Aber du hast doch jetzt den Anfang, also die vorherigen Minuten dieser Sendung gehört, oder? Und die ganzen Use Cases, die Nutzungsszenarien hast du ja auch schon gehört. Also dass jetzt eben auch im Iran jemand sein Handy zückt, ein Foto macht, oder eben auch bei der Tempelhof-Besetzung, das ins Twitter schiebt und dann hast du das in deinem Twitter-Kline dieses Foto, bevor es irgendwo sonst ist.
Ja, Moment, aber lass mich die Frage nochmal andersherum stellen. Christoph hat da einen interessanten Punkt angesprochen. Er sagte, alles, was er liest, ist eigentlich eher so, Christoph, korrigier mich weg, je das falsche interpretiere, ist eher so, ich geh jetzt die Straße runter und ich mach mir jetzt eine Pizza und ich sitze da am Rechner.
Er hat gesagt, das sind Links auf Blogs.
Nee, nee, ich hab gesagt, das sind meistens irgendwelche Links.
Oder Links auf Blogs, okay.
Also ich mein, selbst Bilder sind ja nur Links auf irgendwelche anderen Seiten.
Okay, ist die Frage jetzt, wie man interessante Inhalte findet?
Nee, der Punkt ist doch, ist doch egal. Ich meine, das muss man ja gar nicht irgendwie finden. Das schadet der Blogosphäre kein Stück. Ganz im Gegenteil, es ist ein weiteres Medium, über dem Aufmerksamkeit für Blog-Einträge gemacht wird. Blog-Einträge haben einfach eine ganz andere Informationskultur.
Ich wollte damit auch gar nicht sagen, dass ich prinzipiell Twitter schlecht finde. Ich denke nur, es wird jetzt im Moment ein bisschen gehypt und deswegen überbewertet. Also ich denke, wenn dieser ganze Hype, dass jetzt halt sehr viele neue Leute in Twitter kommen, ein bisschen vorbei ist, dann wird es irgendwann eigentlich gar nicht mehr so interessant sein. Also es ist ja schon jetzt so, dass unüberschaubar viele Leute in Twitter sind. Und momentan ist es modern, wenn ein Politiker irgendwie einen Twitter-Account hat und da tweetet. Aber ich meine, wie lange wird es dauern, bis die CDU dann auch langsam erkennt, das ist ein tolles Medium, wo man schön mehr oder weniger auch seine Propaganda verbreiten kann und dann mehr oder weniger da auch...
Aber Christoph, erinnere dich mal...
Get it on, sage ich nur. Ich meine, die werden da ganz schön Schiffbruch erleiden, wenn sie da nichts anderes als Propaganda machen.
Erinnere dich mal an die Zeit, als Webblogs gerade hip wurden, als das irgendwie auch immer mehr explodierte und jeder plötzlich anfing zu bloggen. Das tat ja an sich dem Medium-Blog keinen Abbruch. Ein Großteil der Blogs ist jetzt irgendwie versandet irgendwo so vor sich hin. Aber die lesenswerten Blogs gibt es ja weiterhin und deswegen hat er trotzdem eine Aufmerksamkeit für das Blog an sich geschaffen und so ähnlich wird es auch mit Twitter werden.
Und nicht so auf Twitter als solches versteifen. Wie gesagt, wenn Twitter tot ist, kommt das nächste und das wird noch schneller sein und noch größer und noch mehr vernetzt. Das ist jetzt eine Evolutionsstufe und irgendwann kommt die nächste. Das Sendungsbewusstsein der Leute nimmt ja eher zu als ab. Das glaube ich kann jeder schon mal bestätigen. Und welches Medium sie dann am Ende nutzen?
Also es ist halt so im Moment sind halt hauptsächlich auch wirklich Leute, die sich selber mitteilen wollen in Twitter. Also ich bin da insofern auch keine Ausnahme. Ich schreibe halt alles, was irgendwie ein bisschen, wo ich nur einen Satz oder so dazu zu sagen habe, schreibe ich dann halt in Twitter oder sowas rein, wenn ich irgendwo bin.
Warte, da habe ich noch was.
Ich verstehe nicht so ganz genau, was du jetzt sozusagen eigentlich kritisieren möchtest.
Ich würde sagen, ich finde, man sollte Twitter jetzt nicht unbedingt überwertet werden. Also ich denke, es wird...
Nee, okay, gut, das machen wir jetzt auch nicht.
Dieser Hype, also in jeweil, weil viele Leute sehr begeistert von Twitter sind, auch so im Internet oder so im Freundeskreis und ich finde eigentlich die Tatsache, dass man wirklich nur 140 Zeichen reintun kann, dass man dann nicht mal richtige Links setzen kann, sondern nur URL-Shortener verwenden kann, dass man also auch keine Fotos einbinden kann, sondern zusätzliche Services verwenden kann und dieses ganze komplizierte Drumherum.
Ja, aber offensichtlich hält das die Leute nicht davon ab, das zu benutzen.
Ich finde es ein bisschen kurz. Es kommt doch alles rüber.
Okay, wir haben das jetzt verstanden. Du findest, dass es eigentlich nicht geeignet ist. Ich sag dir, die Leute finden ihren Nutzen dafür und dass das jetzt gehyped wird. Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass es so ein Hype-Ministerium gibt, wo dann irgendwas gehyped wird. Das hat ja auch einen Grund, warum das in der Diskussion ist. Darüber reden wir ja hier im Prinzip auch gerade. Das ist da einfach eine Menge Anwendungen dafür.
Wie gesagt, für so Sachen wie jetzt im Iran, finde ich jetzt sehr schön, dass eben da Twitter jetzt eine Anwendung findet. Aber ich denke mal, das ist jetzt momentan so, das wird sich jetzt auch helfen. Immer wenn irgendwo irgendwas passiert, vermute ich mal...
Das passiert schon seit zwei Jahren. Das ist auch nicht nur im Moment so.
Ja gut, vielleicht habe ich es auch noch nicht so mitbekommen, aber ich denke, das wird mit der Zeit die Leute auch irgendwann langweilen, dass man ständig, also dass quasi jeder das jetzt macht.
Okay, die Wette gilt. Ich sage dir, es wird anders sein.
Ich habe ja wie gesagt selber einen Twitter-Account und ich finde es wirklich wahnsinnig unübersichtlich, teilweise da irgendwelche sinnvollen Informationen herauszuziehen. Dementsprechend, da finden wir eben Blogs lieber.
Das ist ja vollkommen okay. Wir sagen mir auch gar nichts gegen. Wir sagen auch nicht, dass du jetzt nur Twitter und nichts anderes benutzen sollst, sondern natürlich alle anderen Medien auch. Das ist ja ganz klar. Und zu diesen 140 Zeichen wollte ich einfach noch mal kurz sagen, das führt halt auch dazu, das habe ich auch erst kritisiert und dachte, nee, das ist ja blöd und wieso. Aber das führt halt auch dazu, dass wirklich jeder Tweet sehr kondens ist, dass die Information sehr dicht ist. Du hast halt nur 140 Zeichen, da musst du jetzt halt auch deinen Punkt rüberbringen und nicht irgendwie bla, Fasel, Blob und drei Zeilen Einleitung, sondern du hast 140 Zeichen, da ist mein Punkt peng, fertig, aus. Und ich finde das halt auch sehr charmant und viele andere eben auch, dass es dazu führt, dass eben die Informationsdichte durchaus auch...
Früher stand an den deutschen Telefonzellen so ein netter Satz.
Fasse dich kurz.
Ich denke nur, das wird irgendwann dann auch sein Ende dann nie mehr in ein, zwei Jahren.
Krisser, wann auch immer, wir können es etwas salopp zumachen und können sagen, es entwickelt sich und wir sind alle mit dabei. Danke dir, schönen Abend.
Imminent Death of the Net predicted, sage ich dazu nur. Kennst du das? Das ist noch so aus den guten alten Tagen, als das Internet noch fast überhaupt niemandem bekannt war und dann so in den Newsnet-Foren, das war sozusagen das erste Twitter, wo sie irgendwie alle waren, wo dann immer mehr kamen und dann permanent die Verrohung und die Versinnlosung der Diskussion angeklagt wurde. Und dann kam halt daraus sozusagen ein eigenes Meme, was unter diesem Begriff Imminent Death of the Net predicted. Also wenn das so weitergeht, dann wird irgendwie alles vorbei sein.
Dann kommt immer was Neues. Also was aber passiert, was wir viele von euch erzählt haben, dass du Twitterst und merkst, es gibt Leute, die haben eine ähnliche Meinung wie du und selbst wenn du dich mit denen nur über welches Medium auch immer erstmal in Kontakt trittst mit dem, um dann irgendwann mit denen vielleicht mal zu telefonieren, um dich dann im wirklichen Leben auch mal mit denen zu treffen. Also wenn das das Resultat ist, was da hinten bei rauskommt, dann herzlichen Glückwunsch, was ein geiles Tool.
Haben wir noch Anrufer?
Haben wir noch. Wir haben noch Oliver am Telefon. Hallo Oliver.
Ein Aspekt, den ihr jetzt schon, oder zwei Aspekte, die ihr kurz angeschnitten habt, die ich kurz mal herausdeuten wollte, ist, für mich hat Twitter mittlerweile fast den Status eines Newsreaders erreicht. Also anstatt mir Feeds in mein NetNews-Wild zu packen oder so, folge ich einfach ein paar Leuten auf Twitter oder auch einigen Blog-Robotern, die automatisch Blogposts in Tweets umwandeln. Und auf die Art und Weise stolpert man über Dinge, die man sonst vielleicht nie gefunden hätte. Seiten, die man sonst nie anschaut, nicht in seinem Newsfeed hat, aber da ist ein interessanter Artikel jetzt zur Iran-Wahl oder zur Zinsursala. Tim, du bist ja auch sehr aktiv und auch über dich habe ich einige interessante Dinge gefunden. Und ja, also man stolpert über sehr viele interessante Dinge. Und die ganzen Dienste, die sich vorher an diesen Punkt versucht haben, was man so diese 20 Icons, die man unter jedem Newspost auf diversen Seiten findet, delicious, dick, yick und wie sie alle heißen, mit denen konnte ich nie was anfangen. Ich weiß nicht, aber das hat mir nie was gebracht.
Geht mir ganz genauso.
Also gab es ja auch hier früher schon mit den Blogs Technorati hatte ja auch mal eine ganz große Hype-Phase, wo dann eben die Blogs da aggregiert wurden und Themen und Trends und haste nicht gesehen. Aber ich habe mich auch schon gefragt, wieso das jetzt bei Twitter eigentlich so anders ist. Aber ich glaube, es liegt auch einfach daran, dass man jetzt halt so Clients hat, wo man halt alles in eine macht. Man kann halt Suchwörter tracken, man hat die Followers. Man kann schön faul sein, sich zurücklehnen und das rieselt so auf einen hinein, ohne dass man noch weiter klicken müsste.
Das ist so Internet-Fernsehen der neuen Generation.
Und ein zweiter Punkt, den ihr auch schon kurz besprochen hattet, Twitter ist ja auch ein wunderbares Werkzeug für das so schön beschriebene Crowdsourcing. Also wenn ich ein Problem habe, wenn ich irgendeine Information suche, wenn mir irgendein was auch immer fehlt, dann blase ich einen kurzen Tweet in die Welt hinaus. Da gibt es ja auch den schönen Dienst LazyTweet. Den könnt ihr vielleicht nachher auch mal kurz erwähnen.
Wir liest noch mal dieses ehemalige Nachrichtenmagazin aus Hamburg. Mir fällt es gerade nicht an.
Also ich bin auch so zu Twitter gekommen, tatsächlich, weil ein Kumpel von mir hatte ein Problem hier mit seinem Rechner und hat das irgendwie einfach ins Twitter gehauen und dann hat er irgendwie auch ein paar Minuten später von dem Entwickler von der Software einen Tipp bekommen und dann dachte ich mir, ach so, das kann man nicht nur benutzen für ich gehe jetzt mal baden oder so, sondern man kann da auch richtig dieses Crowdsourcing machen und ich habe selber auch echt schon diverse, unerwartete und ungeplante solche Erlebnisse gehabt, wo ich einfach irgendwie über was gerantet habe und dann kommt halt von irgendwie einem anderen Open Source Projekt einer an und sagt, hier probier doch mal unser Projekt, so ist auch ganz gut. Dann habe ich mir das angeguckt, war super und habe ihm nochmal ein Danke zurückgeschrieben und ohne, dass ich halt irgendwas jetzt groß dafür getan hätte. Also dieses Crowdsourcing ist auf jeden Fall auch ein ganz, ganz großer Punkt, der Twitter für mich irgendwie auch sehr attraktiv macht.
Oliver, dann war's das. Dankeschön. Wir haben noch einen aus, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ruft Markus aus Österreich an. Hallo Markus. Servus, guten Abend. Von wo rufst du an, genau? Ja, jetzt bist du wieder da. Von wo rufst du an? Aus Wien? Okay.
Und ich wollte eure Diskussion zum Schluss noch mal irgendwie aufs eigentliche Thema Twitterdemokratie zurückbringen. Es war jetzt viel die Rede von Twitter allgemein. Und ich hab das Gefühl, also ich hab da letztens einen Tweet gelesen von Philipp Bande und er hat irgendwie geschrieben, 1980 Ökologie, 2009 Internet. Ich fand das sehr treffend. Weil was wir jetzt irgendwie sehen, ist ja das erste Mal, irgendwie kollektive Systeme in die Politik zu halten. Also ich hab das Gefühl, dass wir in ein, zwei Jahren vielleicht gar keine Institutionen wie Parteien verbrauchen werden für politische Prozesse. Also dass wir Systeme wie das Web 2.0, also Systeme des Web 2.0, wie Flickr, Wikipedia etc. jetzt quasi auch in diese Politik hineintragen.
Also ich glaub, Philips Kommentar bezog sich vor allem auf diese aktuelle Diskussion rund um die Piratenpartei, dass halt damals die Ökologie einen großen Teil der Bevölkerung mobilisiert hat, was dann eben zur Gründung der Grünen führte. Und das ist jetzt die bemühte Analogie in Bezug auf die Piratenpartei, die sicherlich auch in vielerlei Hinsicht überhaupt nicht vergleichbar ist mit den Grünen. Aber natürlich dieser Hintergrund, Internet jetzt sozusagen als das neue kulturelle Phänomen, was einfach einem zunehmend größer werdenden Gruppe der Gesellschaft sehr wichtig ist. So wie es eben zu dem Zeitpunkt eben die Ökologie war. Das war sehr wichtig und es war auch so wichtig, dass man gesagt hat, ich unterstütze eine Partei, die jetzt im Prinzip nur, naja, also den Grünen zu unterstellen, sie hätten damals nur ein Thema gehabt. Das wäre auch falsch, weil da steckt ja viel drin. Friedensbewegungen und so weiter. Aber natürlich war Ökologie da ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt. Und ist ja auch heute noch. Und so ist es eben jetzt auch, dass es eine große Gruppe von Leuten gibt, die sagen, uns ist jetzt die Zukunft der Freiheit, der Informationsfreiheit, der Kommunikationsfreiheit so wichtig, dass wir da so einen großen Augenmerk drauf richten und das auch so breit diskutieren, obwohl dadurch andere politische Aspekte vielleicht jetzt gerade mal nicht so im Mittelpunkt der Diskussion stehen, die uns sonst auch wichtig wären. So habe ich das verstanden. Aber mit den Parteien bist du da so sicher, also bin man nicht so sicher, ob das jetzt wirklich der Tod der Parteien ist oder so. Das wird sich glaube ich eher ändern als...
Ja, ich glaube, dass immer mehr politische Entscheidungsfindung vielleicht auch ohne Institutionen möglich sein wird. Durch diese direkte Beteiligung breiter Massen.
Das wäre aber auch schon mal ein Gewinn, wenn man sozusagen überhaupt in deren Entscheidungsfindung damit eingreifen könnte, was derzeit eigentlich nur dadurch möglich ist, dass man selber da drin ist.
Und da hab ich das Gefühl, dass die Parteien das noch nicht verstehen.
Wie ist denn das mit Twitter eigentlich in Österreich? Wir haben jetzt viel über deutsche Debatten gesprochen.
Es gibt eine extrem aktive Gemeinde, insbesondere hier im Wiener Raum. Ganz spannende Diskussionen jetzt gerade hier im Wiener Kontext zum Thema Grüne Landespartei, die irgendwie laut ihrer Statuten eine sehr basisdemokratische Ausrichtung haben, wo festgehalten ist, dass jeder, der sich offen zu dieser Partei bekennt, auch an dieser Partei, in dieser Partei mitarbeiten darf. Das hat jetzt eine große Gemeinde hier in Wien. Hauptsächlich wird Twitter sehr ernst genommen und sich organisiert und wollte da jetzt irgendwie für die kommenden Parteiversammlungen ein Stimmrecht erlangen. Wurde dann aber sehr schnell abgeschmettert von dieser Partei, von Teilen dieser Partei, die wohl irgendwie Angst haben, dass über diese Bewegung die Partei übernommen wird.
So wie damals die FDP in Berlin.
Und die einfach noch nicht verstehen, welche Chance sich da auftut durch die Beteiligung, die jetzt einfach möglich wird durch diese widerschwellige Chance.
Ich greife mal dein Wort auf und sage, Chancen, die entstehen, da sind wir gerade Zeuge der Entwicklung, was mit Twitter und vielen anderen Feeds gerade passiert, welche Kommunikationsmittel sich bieten durch das Netz, durch Web 2.0 dadurch, dass du mit Leuten kommunizieren kannst, ohne auf einen bestimmten Punkt einen Rechner oder eine Kneipe oder was angewiesen zu sein. Wahrscheinlich ist das alles nur der Anfang von dem, was da irgendwann mal kommt und wir bleiben weiterhin gespannt. Markus, dir schönen Gruß nach Wien und schönen Abend noch. Wir müssen jetzt nämlich echt die Segel streichen, weil gleich kommt Tobi Koch mit Night Flight. Das war's Chaos Radio auf Fritz zum Thema Twitter mit Huckel und Tim. Chaos Radio Express, nächstes Thema, Tim? Mach noch ein bisschen.
Das nächste Thema? Ich kündige normalerweise meine Themen im Vorfeld nicht an. Das ändert sich genau heute. Die nächste Thema ist Tech.
Und hier noch eine andere Ankündigung im CCCB. Also im Chaos Computer Club Berlin findet morgen, glaube ich, ein Datengarten statt, auf den ich hier hinweisen sollte. Das findet ihr auch noch mal auf berlin.ccc.de. Und als Abschlusswort hier nochmal, hätte ich ja auch gerne nochmal das hier eingespielt. Jetzt müsste der Chat hier explodieren.
Vielen, vielen Dank für eure Anrufe. Noch mal hören geht entweder auf fritz.de oder aber auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Da steht der Podcast dieser und auch von allen anderen Sendungen. Wir hören uns dann spätestens in vier Wochen wieder zum nächsten Chaos Radio hier gleich an Neidfeld auf Fritz. Tschüss, tschau, bis bald.